I am needing to get my own place um in I
mean ASAP my income is fairly low and my
monthly bills are pretty high my income
is um 2,300 monthly what do you do um I
process medical records right now okay
I've been looking around to see what I
can do um but with no no degree and no
not a hold back at all yeah I I live in
rural Tennessee I saw a sign the other
day that said McDonald's said $20 an
hour
yeah I do I am I do have a side hustle
that I am starting um after the holidays
are over I'm starting a side hustle and
that'll be like $15 an hour but that's
only the weekend that I can do a side
hustle because my job now is a 9 to5 so
what what happens after five I do have a
well I kind of have a one-year-old my
boyfriend um has a one you can't kind of
have a one-year-old that's impossible